[Applause]
we're gonna have some fun tonight right
we have fun for a couple reasons one
we've got kids in the front row and that
means chaos people right - we got two
c-span here let's hear for c-span right
defense there is no better dirtier crowd
in the Washington DC metro area in fact
all the viewing and viewers of c-span I
think are in this room right now we love
you I will watch on a regular basis I
mean the regular viewers of course and
so we welcome everyone to see spam and
but there's a couple other things I'm
going to do nowhere else and we're going
to do here so first I'm going to tell
you about the difference between history
and destiny and we all know what history
is right it's what happened but destiny
is what must happen and this is true I
can't even believe this is happening but
my father may he rest in peace was
struck by lightning his father my
grandfather I'm not joking was struck by
lightning right that means don't stand
next to me in a rainstorm and last week
I was telling my son this story and
telling him listen I would my dad was
struck by lightning
his dad was struck by lightning and he's
like oh my gosh we could be struck by
lightning and as he says I'm like you
won't be but sure yeah you might be
tonight this is true my son and my
family might my wife and my kids were
taking the Amtrak train from New York
City here in Washington DC for this
event and their train was struck by
lightning
my son texted me he's like you are not
going to believe what happened tonight
Destinee people that is what we are
witnessing here so you're going to see
those they'll come running in late but
this is destiny so a couple other things
that I'm going to single out which we
can't do anywhere else in the country
first of all where is Jim day once they
think of Jim Jim right here at Jim stand
up one second this is Jim who runs and
there's so much work for the lost
history and Lego versions of me and all
these other things gets to be here I
love you thank you for all you do I
assume you got rid of all your stickers
and everything's gone so again find Jim
if you want a sticker of a LEGO version
of me Jim has them so when you need them
Jim's your man and he's like a drug
dealer of Lego stickers now you've got
one oh good thank you that does look
like me
so this is yours so now here's the other
person I want to thank I don't get to do
this anywhere else Amy
raise your hand please so this is Amy
when we call our Amy Wagner Wagner
Amy it was a couple years ago my history
teacher contacted me saying that she was
sick and she needed a kidney or she
might die and we put it on my Facebook
page and amazingly people actually said
you know what Brad and I said this is
the teacher chain might changed my life
gave me my love of history could you
donate a kidney to save her and of all
the people that I couldn't believe
volunteered there was one person who
said hey Brad I volunteer but I didn't
hear from the teacher and they never
heard back and I was like you know why
you're going to hear back don't worry
you know she's really busy but for
whatever reason I took that email and I
forward and I said listen one slip
through the cracks you know one that we
missed and that person who we missed was
Amy and what happened was when they got
the email they contacted her and they
emailed me back me so you're not going
to believe is that woman you sent us she
was the match and so what was it six
months away at six six months just six
months ago Amy came down to Florida
where I live with Miss Sherman's lives
and Amy gave her kidney to my history
teacher and we actually checked no we're
going to give you a better reason the
cob we actually checked and we said
whatever happened that original email
and they finally checked that weekend
and they said it went to Spano was gone
forever
um so again history and destiny amulets
here for EMU gave a body part to a
stranger come on people so if you want
to be a better person
go donate a body part to a stranger if
you do you get to be first in line
tonight I'm just telling you anyone who
donate now where is that kid where is
the kid who has a playoff game that's
you okay so you got a so this kid right
here I get an email on Facebook this is
true this kid has a championship little
league game tonight
he said he's skipping his game don't run
of this story the world series of Little
League tonight he says he's skipping it
because he wanted to come here to the
book signing and his mom told me that
his dad is the coach of the team is that
true does the coach of him dad is so mad
night son is here tonight with mom
coming to the front of the line let's
hear from the kid who actually can hear
that applause and a falling one literacy
gets you right not for because when
literacy can buy true and then who's
here if it is always here from the
National Archives I know someone's here
someone told me they were here they've
in the back they're going to raise their
hand mr. shy because archivists are shy
but I know who they are and I can't
squat them right now but thanks to my
friends who are from the National
Archives the archivist united states
emailed me just as I was coming out and
he said look for them they're coming so
thank you to everyone from the National
Archives who helps with these books and
to my wife and to my kids who face
lightening to get here again if you want
to be a better person a me and give a
kidney then you have to fight lightning
and if you do you also get to the front
of the line and now we'll bring you
bring us here to the house of secrets so
now we've talked we talked about destiny
let's talk about history this book was
written by myself and Todd Goldberg and
you know people always say where the
book ideas come from and to me a good
idea is a living thing and someone once
told me that a good idea that if you
don't do it eventually someone else will
do it and that terrified because I had
this idea for five years stuck with me I
didn't know what to do with him and it
kept sticking with me I know how to get
rid of it but I was like this is going
to keep going we have to
this out we have to do this story and
the story started for me when I was in
the National Archives and I was in what
they call the treasure vault and the
treasure of all is where they keep all
the really good stuff not open to the
public and they took me in the back room
they handed me the sheet of paper that
looked like a paperback book if you
turned it sideways and on this paperback
on this sheet of paper it was an oath of
allegiance that George Washington gave
to his top members of the military to
sign to swear I solemnly swear I will
never betray these new United States and
he had numbered them so number one in
the top corner number two number three
four five and number five the fifth one
was signed by a guy named Benedict
Arnold and in that moment you know
Benedict Arnold is a name that we kind
of call each other right we say you know
don't be a Benedict Arnold something
like a curse word for you know people
who love history but in that moment
Benedict Arnold wasn't some name that
you call someone Benedict Arnold was a
decorated officer who fought for this
country displayed sling country and was
rewarded and then promoted and was part
of that inner circle of George
Washington and better the door wasn't a
bad name anymore he was a real person to
put pen to paper on this sheet of paper
and I just couldn't shake that and then
I heard this story which really cracked
the book open is the last moments
between Benedict Arnold and George
Washington are among the most
heartbreaking in US history because they
were dear friends they were like the
BFFs of the revolutionary set right and
what happened was is when Benedict
Arnold betrays George Washington
reportedly they say that it's one of the
only times George Washington has ever
seen crying and that image of George
Washington the father of our country
crying stuck with me and then I heard
this detail that Benedict Tolliver a
letter and Alexander Hamilton faded did
not even deliver it in rap or song but
he did deliver this letter from Benedict
Arnold to George Washington and in this
letter from Benedict Arnold he said
three things yes for three things from
George Washington he said one don't kill
my wife she didn't know I was a traitor
too he said don't tell the staff they
didn't know I was a traitor either I did
this myself and three and one of the
craziest moments of letter-writing
history he says do me a favor can you
please send me my baggage and my
belongings and this guy just put a knife
in the back of George Washington he's
the most hated man since Judas himself
and he basically says hey can I have my
stuff and the amazing part is to this
day nobody knows what was in that
baggage that George Washington sent back
to Benedict our but he did send it back
he sent the baggage back and nobody
knows what was in that baggage now I do
not want to ruin chapter 85 of the house
of secrets but on chapter 85 you will
see my theory and I couldn't shake that
idea and so for five years over you know
half a decade I finally am like I gotta
figure out how to do this idea and I and
that's where I met Todd Goldberg my
co-writer on this book and when you pair
with someone else to write you have a
choice right you can do you can pick
someone who you think is worse than you
someone who is as good as you and
someone who's better as you is better
than you that's your choice and to me I
was like I know my I know what I'm
thinking I want the guy who's better
than me I want the guy who can do
something that I think I can't do can
accomplish thing that I worry that I
struggle with and Todd is an amazing
literally you know they try to give me
the publisher tried for years that's
going to do career books had no interest
and they said you know pair up with a
mystery writer pair up with a thriller
writer and there was some that I would
have loved to work with but we're busy
but for the most part I said you know
what they're just going to give me more
plot I got plenty of plot I want someone
who could do character like nothing I've
ever seen before and I instead I went
and found I found a literary writer I
found Todd who's amazing a character he
kills a character and what I love is
that Todd's book gangster land a
wonderful book I highly recommend came
out in the six months after we were
working together and the book got
nominated there was over like book of
the year he lost to a guy named Stephen
King and I publish it was like boy he
working with him like I know he is a
killer trust me and what I love about
this book and how it's been received and
the great reviews we've gotten is that
it's because Todd and I really together
did something that neither of us alone
could do
and so what happened is you know we knew
that I knew always knew the opening
scene of this book and it was in the
story this girl named hazel who sits on
her father's lap and here's a story for
the first time a gruesome story and she
hears the story that she said again six
years old her dad hosts a conspiracy TV
show right I don't write any books
unless I live that people definitely do
this and he tells these stories to her
that in the Revolutionary time who was a
frozen body that was found and he says
that this body when they did this
rudimentary autopsy they opened it up
and inside the body was a thing of wax a
block of wax that contained something
and they cut open the wax and in there
is a priceless book a book that belongs
to Benedict Arnold and this little
six-year-old girl says tell it again
i'ma write this gross different than
everyone else Hazel's the kind of girl
puts her hand on the stove and burns it
and the next day she comes back and she
puts a different hand on the stove and
burns it again just to see and compare
the pain different than all of us and so
let's talk about the book the book opens
up and hazel wakes up in the hospital
she's grown out thirty years old she
wakes up and she is in the hospital and
has no memory and she finds out there's
been an accident her father's now dead
the host of this conspiracy TV show and
the FBI tells her that the last person
that her father was seen with they found
him dead and when they cut open his body
they found in hazel says her first
memory that she can recall is they found
a book that belonged to Benedict Arnold
and in that moment she realized that the
stories our dad told her as a little
girl had truth to them that warning to
them they had advice to them and they
were all just for her almost like a
training of his daughter all these years
and from there she finds guns that are
in her house she doesn't know how they
got there she finds scars on her body
she does remember and can't recall those
and she quickly realized that only by
solving this murder can she figure out
who killed her father and also who she
really is
she is the mystery of this book write to
me a great bada's great plot but the
best plot is a great character and Hazel
herself as the character she has no
memory
she can't remember people that she
mention is what's called emotional
memory loss so it's not mu which is like
a scooby-doo plot right no one gets
amnesia but when she has emotional
memory loss which is means that the
people that she was most connected to
she heard she's forgotten them so she
can walk into a bar and that guy that
she's attracted to she doesn't know if
it was someone she loves or her worst
enemy and now everywhere she goes into
venture and everywhere she goes she
feels like maybe I wasn't a nice person
she reads people they're like oh my gosh
please don't start trouble again
and she's like again and she has this
moment where she can relive her life she
restored her life and I love that as a
character as her as a character because
everything becomes an adventure in that
moment and everything is new and think
about a firm own will we all if we could
take a moment knock ourselves in the
head with a hammer and start over and
have our lives anew I would go pick out
a really nice hammer right it's just an
amazing idea and to me what I loved
about it is as we came up with it is
impaired perfectly with this idea that
I've been carrying around for five years
and it's Benedict Arnold and to me the
fun of it is right Benedict all we all
think of as the bad guy of the story but
he's not the bad guy or the good guy
what Benedict Arnold is is all like all
of us he's the complicated guy he's a
complicated man we're all not good we're
not bad we're all good and we are all
bad but we are all complicated and I
realize in hazel as she finds this life
that she used to have and this life that
wasn't so good and she has a chance to
suddenly be good she gets to be just
like Benedict Arnold on some days good
on some days bad judged like the rest of
us flawed like the rest of us we are all
amazing and we are all terrified we are
all brave and we are all cowards we are
all stupendous some of us all in the
very same day that's who we are as
people and I really and time I really in
this character and in this plot we can
explore not just hazel but the stories
of Benedict Arnold and what it means to
be good and what it means to be bad and
what our identity is really about and
the fun of it is of course that I fill
it with real history I always loved that
stuff and when I was researching this
book I can talk about it here because
you know by the way half the great
sources I have or hidden in this crowd
right now because I see a couple of them
I try to look around people judge each
other
judge each other completely it's
Washington DC in Virginia and here's
what so here's one of the things that
happen when I was researching the book I
met this military intelligence officer
and I said to where does the United
States get best information where is its
best intelligence come from and one of
the things that they said to me and he
said to me so there's a true story as he
said that years ago there was a dictator
who hated the United States this
dictator hated the United States he said
he hated us to what his quote to their
heart and to their bones right down to
his heart into his own and what no one
knew is this dictator through one of his
top lieutenants was actually secretly
working for the United States he was
actually a spy for America and I was
like why you paying money they said no
for the very best reason of all because
a family what happened was is one of his
top lieutenants had a sick child who
needed the kind of medical attention
that only the United States could give
and so we gave this young child medical
attention in exchange this dictator
through this lieutenant gave us
information about terrorists chemical
weaponry out of the hands of extremists
helped us with a financial investigation
that no one knew about you'll see it in
the book and you'll ask yourself huh
that's interesting grab me something I
didn't make it up it's real it happened
and I love that I get to fill the book
with details like that that's why the
house is the the house of secrets opens
and you get to explore hazel and you get
to explore this world and you get to
explore who she is is she good if she
had and of course you get to explore
Benedict Arnold which is so fun to make
this Benedict Arnold is amazing and
obviously that's really where the book
stores what I love to do is also answer
questions about the book because to me
that's also the fun and I can tell
someone here has lots of questions
because she's trying to get my attention
the entire time and so you can ask
anything you want to give you a moment
to think about you can ask about the
kids books you can ask about the
thrillers you can ask about the research
but I will tell you that one thing I
need to say here thank you Barnes &
Noble proposing but thank you to all of
you come every time I really appreciate
but let's get to some questions
and we'll explore some more research yes
I
come on plants please bring it on Teddy
my buddy Leo has a question for you okay
I'm ready leo
hey Leo I'm ready chin down oh this is a
good question so um so the question is
did the Amelia Earhart Lego set come out
now if you haven't seen I'm going to say
now you you're laughing now this is
where I'm going to break your hearts and
I'm going to make you so this is now I'm
going to show you something and maybe we
can see this this is Amelia Earhart I'm
Amelia Earhart lego set now we had
someone build it for us and here's the
thing and now we're putting it on TV so
America is going to help us here's what
happens
Lego love this idea and like I said to
me Brad you're not Star Wars
you're not marble right I'm like I
didn't need you to tell me that I
understand that I know very clearly but
they said we love this and so we'd love
you to put us on our Legos idea webpage
and if you get 10,000 people to vote for
it will consider making it it's how the
Ghostbusters set was made and sound How
I Met Your Mother set was made in fact
how i met your mother said was built by
the woman who built this and if you put
the words so right now we have we just
launched this we have two thousand
people right I can see this crowd is
over two hundred people here so we
better be at at least like twenty-five
hundred Amaro just from you but if you
put the words Lego Amelia Earhart in
Google this will be the first thing that
comes up go to the page register they
just pick your name in your email given
the fake when you give to all the
marketers right and votes this is to me
the point of this was to give my kids
real heroes I love when they can play
with you know Star Wars and those things
but we know one has more light servers
in this room than I do right but I also
love that I can give my kids a Lego set
of amelia earhart of real heroes and if
we do that you know what I want to do
next I want to do a lego Abraham Lincoln
set and I want to do a Lego Albert
Einstein set and a Rosa Parks said every
set we can do and how great would it be
if we can inspire our kids with real
amazing toys to play with so please I
thank you I appreciate it
thank you you guys see it we stayed
there guys got it good
so please Lego Amelia Earhart go vote
and let's see where we go other
questions yes so yes in the back
me Anthony like okay now everyone wants
their own Lego set right this young
smartphone the back says don't worry
don't worry I promise she wants you to
be Anthony who do you want
eleanor roosevelt's like i loved right
this is what you want your kid adds
everywhere
Martin Luther King jr. from the key to
skip Little League right that is I'm
telling you I love that you're just go
ahead give it to me George Washington
right but and this is what I want to do
this is what I want kids in America do
trust me tell your dad dad if you love
the you'll go register for Lego AR
tonight and if you don't register and
vote you don't love me Dad you say those
words and watch what you get that's
other questions Reacher yes on the inner
circle you had a scavenger hunt that you
planted in the book yes do you have
future plans for doing something like
that
yes a look talked about it for those who
don't know I love hiding things in all
my books I can't do a TV show called
decoded without playing some decoded and
one of the things we should talk about
is kind of conspiracies so first a few
things first on this question so in the
book the inner circle I put a secret
code that was hidden in there and if you
crack the secret code that is hidden in
the pages of the inner circle there was
a reward that was there if you got to it
and you found it the reward was hidden
and I'm not telling you where in America
was hidden but you got it it took four
years before someone finally crafted and
Jim day who is sitting here practice
he's the first person to go for years
and Jim crap tips like here for Jim
now Jim also loves a good little code so
Jim also was kind enough to put it back
it is out there it is still there
it is hidden for the taking if you want
the treasure it's hidden in the pages of
the inner circle I will promise one
thing Jim will not tell you where it is
he's not going to tell you but it is
still there I will not tell you anything
else that I've hidden over the years but
there are hidden things in the kids
books
I am hidden in every book I thought you
saw that all right see God just look for
the guy who looks like me right and
you'll see and when you think I'm the
only thing and there are so many things
hidden in the his books you'll never
find I hide my number 27 and I do hide
into the next kids book a well toy hi
child I don't hide that but I will say
the same things in lots of books we had
lots of comic book references and lots
of fun things and the number 27 is very
symbolically special to me anyone who
watches decoded will know why as well
but I will say that let's talk about
conspiracies and about decoding as I
mentioned it is here's the thing is
right now I hosted four years a
conspiracy TV show and conspiracies used
to be something that were really a
fringe thing they really were that's
what they were they were on the fringe
and you if you love conspiracies you
would sit in the garage and the corner
was like comic books right if you love
comic books you were a fringe group you
need maybe not in a holiday in somewhere
once a month and no one really cared
about you that's how San Diego started
and then suddenly comic books are on
every three sisters I'm not even joking
and and comic books now are on every
screen on every television and it's the
same thing with conspiracies they are
now mainstream we used to live in a
world where is you only you additi a
crackpot to talk about conspiracies and
now yeah Donald Trump talking about you
know Ted Cruz's dad being involved with
Lee Harvey Oswald or Vince fostering
when Hillary saying that she's going to
release records on UFOs if she is
elected the two main candidates running
for the Presidency are literally talking
about major mainstream conspiracies they
are not just these fringe
anymore and what happened what I love
that we do get to do in the house of
secrets one of the fun parts of writing
a book with one of the main characters
hosts the conspiracy TV show is I get to
explore what it was like to host that
show and the fun of it for me was I
realized over time that people tell me
secrets they tell me secrets and I've
had the Department of Homeland Security
call me in and bring me in I've had
presidents of the United States and
write me letters I've gone George HW
Bush that wanted to come and spend a
week in Houston and they time people
from Fort Knox said to me they want to
talk to me about whether there's real
gold and Fort Knox anymore in fact I got
one day through one of the their lawyers
the family of John Wilkes Booth who shot
Abraham Lincoln tracked me down and said
to me it was amazing moment said this is
the family of John Wilkes Booth the
lawyer said and they everyone knows if
you read any history book it says 12
days after Abraham Lincoln was shot John
Wilkes Booth was then killed and this is
his family and they say they shot the
wrong guy he actually escaped and they
have the proof of brab you want to hear
that story yes I want to hear that story
all right I want to hear that story and
so to me I would I love that people tell
me the secret I went to a private lunch
in the White House I walked in at
private lunch in the president's private
dining room came out no one looked twice
to me why why they tell me serious
because I write thrillers for a living
because I hosted a TV show about
conspiracies and I really I'm the
perfect spy I am I am and the thing is
that the more I insisted the more you
laugh and the more you go maybe he's
telling the truth and you know what
that's just what I want you to think
right that's it I have the perfect cover
because I can go anywhere and everyone
just thinks I'm doing fun research for
another thriller and I said how do I not
use that idea in the next book so
obviously the house of Secrets creates
that and the fun of it is also the other
side of what when you work on this and
when what happens is is when
conspiracies become so mainstream when
you have presidential candidates talking
about them there is what develops is a
true industry of conspiracy that's all
we're in now it's a true industry and
you can know all the people who kind of
regular
do it and they do it in the most odd
ways and árbol has never been about
fear-mongering or just saying every
government is always out to get you or
you know everywhere the Freemasons are
stealing your car right now but it's
been about trying to give the hardest
thing of all for the American people
this is what the coded is founded on is
we're going to try and tell you the best
story of all the true story and I
remember when we first started filming
decoded one of the producers said to me
that the less facts you have on shows
like this the more scary music in play
that the industry of conspiracy and
that's sad to me and I'm when I sent we
said we will never do that show I never
want to be part of that show but you'll
see when you read the house of secrets
you'll see what it's like from the
inside of what it's like to be one of
these people who get to host a
conspiracy TV show and what needs to be
regularly involved I mean because of
that people come to me I've had someone
at a book signing come and bring me the
Holy Grail at an event all these amazing
things just because of the job I have
and I love that I get to do that and
obviously so codes and secrets and all
those things are forever a part of this
project and all the projects I work on
yes another no yes I want things I don't
like it I don't know why
you I'm not sure what that question is
she says she likes things she what I
think she oh this was another stray she
said I watched things I don't like and I
don't know why ageism that she said that
after I talk about my own television
show we know who's going to be in the
back of the line today yeah yeah
questions of TV shows and movies so
let's talk about that so we are for
those who love decoded in love lost
history again continue to tell History
Channel they're great we love doing lost
history for the fate of lost history
lost history did everything was supposed
to do it really did that we were so
happy with the ratings so hapless
performance the only issue was as you
I'm sure you realized on your cable
channel is that h2 which is what we were
on history history sister channel
actually got changed over to vice land
Network they just change the channel and
they rebranded it so that's where it
went
we still taught them we love working
with History Channel I will tell you
that we will be looks like filming a
special toward the end of the year and
we're very excited to be doing that so
you will hopefully have something back
soon and as for movies and things like
that I can't say anything but let's just
say that I'm have my fingers crossed for
something really exciting to announce
about the house of secrets very soon so
we're really excited for that one cause
that for a mr. yes Karen um can you tell
us where you got started with storytime
yes storytime I love as anyone knows I
love a good story and so anyone who
follows me on Facebook well we started
realizing this Facebook starting you
know we rolled it on now everyone it's
on everyone's face book page book was
doing live video and I and Facebook said
you can do anything you can put up you
know what you're eating for dinner and
show it live and I was like who wants to
see that but I said you know we could do
with this technology is we can tell
stories
remember on Sunday nights when you know
you were kind of I don't know Sunday
nights for me was like a family night
and I love that idea that on Sunday
night that you you can tell and bring
back the lost art of telling stories so
in sweet what we did is use this
technology and I just got on Facebook
and an 8 o'clock on a Sunday I would
just read stories to people and the
first time we did I think we had like
you know 200 people watching and then we
had you know 300 people watching and
then by the time we got
we did I think like an eight weeks of it
straight with 2,000 people watching live
and when it was done we had a hundred
thousand people who had watched the
video when it was finished to the point
where we had Dave dilky or Captain
Underpants himself came to my house and
he was like this is where your dude was
like the Wayne's world of literacy is
really what it was we were just doing in
my house and he sat there with me my
son's favorite books are Captain
Underpants and we did that and we had
you know in the 50,000 people
it was just incredible to know what the
real number is but it was this amazing
thing I stole and we plan on doing more
story time there is a story time I will
tell you that has been filmed with
someone so famous it is insane I won't
say who it is but it was someone who I
can't say whether it's current or past
but in the White House and it is the
funniest story time I promise you will
ever see and we're just editing and
putting it together it's going to take
us a couple months because we want to
save it for a special moment but story
time is not gone it is coming back so
check out my Facebook page and you'll
see it yes how do we go from writing for
yourself to submitting your color colors
yeah how do you go from just writing for
yourself and then submitting and
publishing the book and I will tell you
that you know when you start writing you
don't ever imagine you're going to be
sitting here and these hands c-span is
going to be here and there's going to be
like you know 250 your closest friends
and you're going to have this time you
just write because you have a story to
tell it's so pure it's so beautiful and
I started writing and because the job
that I went to didn't work out I went to
Boston I moved my stuff to Boston and
the week I got to Boston
my mentor took me under his wing left a
job
MNM Eli Segal I don't my gosh I've
wrecked my life and I did what anyone
any of you would do in a moment what you
think you've wrecked your life I said
I'm going to write a novel right like
that was the most logical thing I could
think of and and I didn't know what I
was doing I just wanted to tell my story
for myself and that first novel got me
24 rejection letters there were only 20
publishers I got 24 rejection letters
right
that means some people wrote me twice to
make sure I was getting their point but
I loved in that year I fell in love with
the process of writing and I said if
they don't like that book I'm going to
write another and if they don't like
that book and write another and the
answer in terms of submitting your book
and you should go too if you go to Brad
notes or calm you'll see on there I put
advice for people who want to write
publish a book but if all you have to do
is get one person to say yes one person
tells you yes one editor and your
published author and your job is to find
that person I don't look back on the
experience and say well look I got 24
rejections and I was right and they were
wrong and hot on them that's a pigheaded
way to look at it what I always look at
that experiences life is subjective so
whenever did you do with your life
whether it's you know you're a teacher
you stay at home you're a lawyer you're
a doc you work in the military whatever
it is you do don't let anyone tell you
know don't let anyone tell you know if
you love it keep doing it and then
you'll submit it and you'll find someone
will say yes and your job is just to
find them but keep going keep going keep
going
other questions will come or yes tickle
questions number one did you kill
yourself off in the book did you read
Mexico yeah I know
okay I'll repeat that gun watch the
second dollar tip oh I just want to
guess I know you went to Michigan to get
about the best economy miss Leland Swift
yes okay so the first one is did you
kill yourself in the book because you
were a character and you said that you
hosted a TV show so did I kill myself I
did I totally did you have the
opportunity now I mean the character I
were in the end in the books you'll see
in the house of secrets what happens to
the character who is supposedly me but
has really nothing to do with me I mean
like the fun part of writing a book
where you have a job I look everyone
look at her no you know that's actually
my favorite part too because that person
feels so bad and now we're going to
totally call attention to her so what I
love that we get to do when you do
something like that is we really do get
to put myself and this world under the
microscope and you'll see in the book
all the different ways and the fun part
that we really do we pick up our
conspiracies is when we become so
obsessed with conspiracies the thing is
when you're in the business of telling
conspiracy stories every once in a while
you got to solve
one because if you don't the audience
thinks you're full of it you got every
once in a while bring a truth you got to
bring up fact you got to bring a
solution and if you don't eventually
they lose faith and they go somewhere
else so that's the ultimate carrot
what's wild is that when Watergate
happens every dream and every nightmare
that everyone had about the government
was suddenly real the government really
was out to get you they really were
lying and the president really was
breaking into your house at night right
at all our fears became true and in that
moment every conspiracy was that was
like water and sunlight for every other
our story that would come after that
especially so close of course the JFK
and to me that's the interesting part
about conspiracies is that we get to in
the pages of the house of secrets even
though it's fiction even though it's a
thriller you get to pull apart what it
makes and then the second question was
about Michigan because I went to
Michigan and what do I think about
what's happening in Flint and of course
no one's in favor it's a disaster but I
will tell you the one of my greatest
moments of my entire life
took place just a couple of weeks ago
because I got to go back I went to Ann
Arbor Michigan the University of
Michigan thank you in the back I
appreciated and they asked me to deliver
the commencement address at Michigan law
school and here was what the amazing
part was that I kind of already gave the
speech before because when I was 22
years old living in Washington DC my
mentor Eli Segal who was person who gave
me that job a new hire bait he actually
was a speech right he hired me as a
speechwriter for AmeriCorps for the
president's national service program and
one of the first speeches that he asked
me to work on for him was his
commencement address at the University
of Michigan Law School and so here I was
from when I was 24 today actually 24
years old and now I was back there at 46
years old and all those years later and
the amazing part when they talked about
in the speech that and I think this is
actually like a really good way to get
one more question about very important
thing that I need to say tonight is one
of the hardest things and the greatest
risks that you'll ever take in your life
is admitting what you want and we all
have to we know what we want but
mint what we want it's hard to admit
what you want right because if you do
you might not get it you might fail but
the way you would know what you want is
you have to admit what you love you have
to admit what scares you and you have to
admit how you and what what brought you
here in the first place and when I was
doing this speech and I never tell this
story but I got to tell it here today
I talked about immediate loving and many
what you fear and when I used to work in
the ovens for a mall used to work at the
haagen-dazs scooping ice cream in the
Aventura Mall in Florida and I remember
this woman came one day and she kept
snapping her finger at me and she was
like serve me
and we actually convinced the the owner
of the store when we were 17 to make us
the managers of the store a friend of
mine and I because we were working there
for so long I worked there I gave a fake
age I worked this in so I was 15 and so
we were the manager of this store
this woman's snapping her fingers saying
servants and man you know I'll be with
you in one second and she's like no
you'll serve me now I said ma'am you
know when you're rude like that I'm not
going to serve you and she snaps her
fingers some more and she doesn't want
to see the manager and I said you know
I'll get the manager for you can I help
you and she says you're not the manager
I said I am and she goes and I said
we're still not going to serve you
because she's just being so rude to
everyone and she said you know what
you're going to work at this miserable
ice cream store for the rest of your
miserable life and I said to her ma'am
if I'm here for the rest of my miserable
life you're still never getting the ice
cream
right and I and I tell that story and I
used to tell that story and laugh and
say always didn't bother me but as I
said there and I should say here it
totally bothered me it made me feel like
my life would be like my own dad's like
it was gum I'm going to be small or I
got had a really rough time with money
and I felt like it was just gonna I was
never going to succeed it made me feel
like my life was delimited somehow in
some way and even though that's a
rational itself it wasn't about you know
the wanting money or wanting success
like that it was just that that fear of
what my data which was no real problems
that were going to be brought on and I
was terrified of that and I realized
that in that moment when I admit what I
fear I also knew that that fear it drove
me its Rove me it drove me to write it
over to succeed its really do everything
it's the reason I'm here today not to
prove some lady wrong but it was my
rocket fuel and to me I and I feel like
it's so important to say and you'll see
it in the pages of the book it's really
right there in the book is for all of
you you know your greatest strengths are
always a greatest weakness but your
greatest weakness at heart is correctly
there's also your greatest strengths
don't find what scares you and let it be
your rocket fuel and as for this isn't
the best part of the story is when I got
to the end of the speech I actually went
and looked back and found the speech
that my mentor Eli Segal that I worked
on when I was 24 years old here in
Washington DC and I tracked down the
speech and I wanted to see this is the
speech that you know had words that I
may or may not have written I couldn't
remember I mean the truth is is I have
no idea when I read the speech what
lines I wrote it in right that is
completely lost to history but what I
did find was the line toward the end of
the speech and the line said this it
says to all of you who are sitting here
today that I hope in 33 years from now
that one of one of you is lucky enough
to be sitting up here and giving this
speech and whoever it is in this
audience that's up there giving it you
are just that you are lucky in other
ways reading the speech I was in my
office crying because I was like oh my
god he's talking to me I Lillian I could
have read
I don't even know but it was like I was
talking to myself that I was an instant
time machine and and I think I will feel
like I need to leave you with this
because it's just the perfect ending but
I feel here today in this town where I
started writing for the first time I
just feel so lucky to be here and I
thank you for supporting me with the
kids books I thank you for supporting me
with the thrillers and it means so much
to me I think one final question and
then we can go from there yes right
there who is your historical figure that
you most identify with and why and also
who is the historical figure over the
centuries or millennia whatever that you
most are inspired by yes question is
this who do I of historical figures do I
identify with and who inspires me and
and you know what it's really that's our
kids book line and real that's what the
core of it is is my values for those who
don't know these books I was tired of my
own kid looking at reality TV show stars
and loudmouth athletes and thinking the
best hero and I said thank so many
better euros for them so we started with
books like I'm Amelia Earhart and I am
Abraham Lincoln we've done I am Albert
Einstein I'm Jackee Robinson we did I am
Rosa Parks we did I'm Lucille Ball
because I wanted my daughter to have an
entertainment hero it wasn't just famous
for being thin and pretty and Lucille
Ball stands but not to say idea that
it's okay to be different but it's
spectacular to be different so I love
that moral weave and I am Helen Keller
and and I am Helen Keller when she goes
blind the pages of the book go black and
it says this is how I see the world
cover your ears
here's how I hear the world and when she
learns to read with real Braille into
the kids book and I am Helen Keller and
says feel these dots this is my name my
name is Helen and it says what's your
name and the real Braille alphabet is
there in the book and I love that Helen
Keller never stops and each book is not
about a person or dates and when they're
born but it's about a moral lesson and
to me it's Helen Keller that says you
know I will never I will know no
limitations or Amelia Earhart's and I
will know no bounds or Lucy being
different or Albert Einstein said it
absolutely always always always be
curious those are my answers that's who
I admire Abraham Lincoln is the one he's
the one for me he's the one that lives
up to the hype every time in his book is
I will always choose kindness and I will
always speak up for others let's shell
Camaro we've got a show right I mean
this is what it says and on the front is
always obviously we're handing over the
most important part of the book is not
what's on from with the most important
part of the moral lesson which we play
we said don't put in the booklet write
on the back you can see it says here I
will always speak my mind and speak for
others that is something to aspire to
for our kids and so I will tell you that
in September we are doing I am George
Washington and then we're doing I am
Jane Goodall which I'm super excited to
do and it's great because you know I
will tell you this is so in the house of
secrets we do a lot of George Washington
and Benedict Arnold but when we did I am
George Washington I was like I'm putting
the cool stuff in the kids book so if we
do away we say to kids listen there's no
cherry tree like let's set them right
don't give them this information but we
also tell them I put this in there a
whole page that says this is how George
Washington is use invisible ink and then
a secret code name was seven-11 and my
editors like do we really need to put
this in there like we totally need in
there and I read these books with my son
and we get to that part he's like oh my
gosh invisible ink that's so cool like I
know tell my ender it's going through so
when you get to I am George Washington
you will see that invisible ink we did
do it I wanted to see if we could do
invisible ink in the book but we got to
figure someone has to figure that out
somewhere all of us I promise you if I
say it now so we'll figure it out for us
maybe in one copy one magic copy how
awesome would that be with my phone
number that will come up and they'll be
a prize
not saying it didn't happen I'm just
saying it could happen and and then we
have we actually will tell you that we
also we're doing after that we discussed
on to six more books so we're going to
be doing 18 of these now so they're
going to keep coming and I'd love to get
to do with that said I'm not going to
tell you who is after that because we're
working on clearances right now it is
the nerdiest best person that comes
after George Washington Jane Goodall I
can't wait to share with you it is so
important but it has to get through
clearances because there's so many
things to be cleared but it's the I
promise if you think you know this is
our level of nerdy for going here we're
going right here so with that said thank
you to everyone coming tonight
and I really really really appreciate
you supporting the house of secrets and
thank the c-span for hosting us always I
have really appreciated so I will sign
everything ok don't move just yet and
really quickly can we give them one more
round of applause to see so awesome
thank you